hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video bei dem
ich mir jetzt gedacht habe dass ich mal
viele youtuber reagieren ja immer
irgendwie so oft alte videos und ich
mache das auch das ist so hip und cool
und ich bin auch hip und cool und danach
sich das passt gut zusammen und halt
dein maul ukw funrun ich habe mir als
video 1 ausgesucht wo ich damals bei
einem kumpel max von mir heißt ja ich
kann glaube ich mag's ich habe beim max
gepennt und wir haben uns gedacht die
auch luca braucht noch ein video
deswegen zocken in minecraft bett wars
und ich habe irgendwie nur so die
tastatur gesteuert und er nur die maus
und deswegen war ich war total schlecht
aber ich hätte das gleiche nochmal einem
video hat mir das video hier jetzt mal
einfach rein gezogen jetzt einfach mal
auf play und wir sehen schon hier geht
das wieder los ich schieße ein pfeil und
ich oh mein gott bin ich schlecht
zwischen direkt denkt was ist das denn
für eine scheiße da ist denke ich mir
gerade was das für eine scheiße ich bin
übrigens gerade im mediaplayer ich habe
das ja sonst irgendwie immer so gemacht
dass ich die datei mir angeschaut habe
und danach er das genau an jeder
einzelnen hat synchronisiert so dass die
qualität besser ist jetzt gerade habe
ich aber nie wirklich nicht so viel zeit
weil bayern münchen gleich spielt und ok
die spielen schon neun minuten und das
video muss halt noch fertig werden heute
deswegen bin ich jetzt mediaplayer
sicher ob weiter oder auch nicht weiter
und weiter und mit lautstärke runter wie
sieht jetzt mal maus so krasse
einblendung lukas die familienprobleme
alter aber das ist echt ich bin sie die
ganze zeit zu machen links rechts
gelaufen und man mit der maus dahin weil
es total komisch sind sowie zwei köpfe
die denken und irgendwo in anderer
richtung laufen wollen wie seht ihr noch
mit jemand anders werten zu finden
zweite runde spielen die totale spaß die
sache denn gott oh mann ich wusste das
festmachen
sorry ultra langweilig videos von
crafter hey was ist das alltag über die
blöcke waren dass du das war irgendwie
so ein texture pack bak und die ganze
blöcke waren die ganze zeit irgendwie so
komisch mit verschiedenen farben oder
das lag am shader hinter ihr werdet die
verfolger locker denken unter dem video
das die diele buses luke für dummkopf
alter so ich habe die komplette
produktivität und siege sicherheit
unseres teams ich habe glück ich
verhalten ohne spaß ich mit so
unprofessionell
es ist einfach so wird man zwei
komplettieren verbrannten menschen zu
schauen sie mich denn die facetime rang
zwei besteuerten menschen zu die banken
gehören kommen sogar oma hat das gold in
der mitte und wir haben viel gemacht
dabei ist er ja der totale oder
erfahrungen als jemand mag sogar diesem
kleinen klapprigen wächter getroffen
wenn wir die scheiße gewinnen möchte ich
mit 20
leixoes sind ja das richtig so freuen
wenn luca und max dieses daher da noch
gewinnen dann will er 20 milliarden
leichter sehen wenig sind ist der dumme
es ist gerade mal drei mal kurz vor 9
und ich oder es liegt wirklich daran
dass sich konkreter videos aber wir sind
immer nur noch eine stimme sind wir
schon bruder kann lokal raum lokal jetzt
hier die sachen rein sammeln mit max und
jetzt fehlen da hinten bekämpfe ich bin
in diesem video echt so ganz abgeschafft
das blöde besser was könnt ihr
eigentlich
kommt luca risso unproduktiven aber
eigentlich ist die idee doch an sich
ultras oder also ich weiss nicht wollten
was vielleicht noch mal dass ich mir was
habe ich da getan gerade wollte das
demnächst vielleicht noch mal dass ich
mir entweder mit max oder vielleicht mit
einem anderen oder keine ahnung wie auch
immer dass ich irgendwie an der
allerdings benannte das wollen wir das
soll ich das noch mal machen weil
irgendwie sieht das ja jetzt gerade
total witzig denen kann man echt nicht
zuschauen
die sind die verrecken die ganze zeit
draußen mein mann alter ja kompakt im
browser an wodurch eine rüstung mit wem
ich wette ich mit den einträgen 1 bei
etwas dagegen nicht gewinnen
ich weiß echt nicht ob ich mir die
chance noch länger gehen kann wenn man
bekommt wenn ich an einem etwa spiele
völlig ja auch nicht einfach so runter
von der erde
was lahm hat der fan schwachsinn du bist
dumm luca vierte zu zweit ist das für
ein schwachsinn video aber wer misst
gedacht wir testen und nicht vor sondern
nehmen das halt einfach mal so springt
auf genau das hat man nicht gemerkt ihr
habt es nicht getestet guck mal was
passiert jetzt aller max zeigt wie wir
das lasse es nämlich echt ey da man man
man manchmal ganz kurze pause wir hatten
hier irgendwie okay ich weiß gar nicht
mich die fans können jetzt gerade hin
gepackt habe wir hatten auf jeden fall
beim bildschirm eine seite
bild von uns dann nochmal unsere hände
da nochmal minecraft da noch mal wieder
alles aufgenommen wird und noch mal die
audition womit wir den tonigen die
aufgenommen haben oder so dann hatten
wir noch fraps in einer ecke und alles
so auf einem bildschirm max hatte zudem
zeit nun ein bildschirm und ist oder hat
er zwei bildschirme hat gar nicht
jedenfalls als ultra stress aufzunehmen
ja wir schon jetzt weiter wenn vor allem
max ein bildschirm deswegen ja auch noch
ein junger mann leute man sich zweimal
das macht keinen sinn gerade rad
vielleicht ein bisschen chaotisch
chaotisch und es war definitiv chaotisch
ja das schlimme warum
luca kabeln ein
damit will ich an dieser stelle beenden
ich hatte ehrlich gesagt für heute keine
idee beziehungsweise was er so was ich
zocken oder hoch deswegen habe ich mir
ein einziges video nochmal angeschaut
und wenn euch das gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen ich
schau jetzt bayern